um so i mean like muse is one of the
only bands i've also seen live streams
they had such amazing hair look yeah
dude
has got the best leash yeah michael
michael jackson's running for his money
on his [ __ ] afro like this this is
like the early days of brady as well
brady like his afro like like now is
like [ __ ] massive
it's huge so yeah i mean i've also seen
brady alive as well i mean like the
reason i put brady up there is because
uh i discovered bradio with sydney
during like a really tough and time
trying time in like our lives when like
i was living in london working for the
bbc i like every every day was like
every day was like depressing as [ __ ] of
course
you know especially with like the
compute that i had but for some reason
for some reason no matter how down my
day was i put on a bradio song and and i
am instantly happy like for just like
that five minutes or three minutes
whatever i could just feel glad and
happy for a second
is it bad i can't remember which songs
they've done which animation they did
death parade over there they're like
that's like i thought it was that yeah i
didn't want to say i don't want to look
at an [ __ ] yeah
put your hands up that song does go hard
yeah i mean like it was so hard it was
it was not only that song but i remember
what really saw me on bradio was first
time i heard that song of course it was
a banger everyone heard the death parade
opening and they knew it was a banger
but it was actually their music video
right because if yeah if you see their
music video it's just like four dudes
having fun with the green screen and
it's just it's like got such this it's
got such a charm to it right because
they do they do this a lot with some of
their music videos where they're just
like taking the piss and like trying to
like try trying to like either
replicate this anime opening because
what they did in this music video was
they've tried to replicate the anime
opening of death parades just with a
shitty green screen four of them and
it's and it was just like using like you
know very basic cosplay and a green
screen and makeup and all the stuff and
it's just it's got such a charm to them
because it just shows that it just feels
like it's four dudes having fun having a
[ __ ] blast and not really giving a
[ __ ] about what the world thinks about
them you know my other favorite music
video by them is a golden liar
where they're just like it's just it's
literally just like them on stage yeah
yeah and they're just [ __ ] having the
time of their life yeah it's such a good
song and it's such a good music video
it's so fun such such a good bass line
as well guys like the funk in that bass
line oh
so good so fun i want to listen to them
yeah you should i i feel i feel like
you'd like them because honestly like
the rest of their like discography is
like nothing but bangers like i haven't
heard a bad radio song yeah uh before we
move on from muse though
like i'm i have like i have a
funny story or not a funny story because
like i remember when i saw them live
uh it was in thailand right and like i
they went to thailand no that's that's
the thing right that's so so it was when
i was living in thailand right and it
was so [ __ ] random because i'd gone
my entire life being a massive muse fan
living in england you know and just
never getting the chance to [ __ ] see
them at all because they they never
performed uh when i was in england and
so like the first time in my life that i
actually got to see them perform was it
in bangkok thailand like what what the
[ __ ] right so i remember like i remember
thinking this is this is this real this
is so surreal that i'm going to be able
to see muse in thailand out of all the
places in the world i could see muse so
i remember going to this concert where
i'm
dragging sydney along because because of
course even though she wasn't as big of
a muse fan as i was i needed something
to go with me yeah and so i remember
like
this was like the highlight of my month
because i'm like [ __ ] me man i get i get
to see muse i get to [ __ ] see muse
and i remember i remember going to go to
the concert and i remember going to um
go to the stage and just like eagerly
excited for them to come on
and i remember the first band that came
on was a band called the ruse
the ruse okay okay so that's that's
r-u-s-e right right
so
i forgot that they needed a supporting
band yeah right i've thought like it's
so
my first thought was
have we just gone to the wrong [ __ ]
concert was was is this a muse concert
or is this
like like what is this like the thai
knockoff of the muse what's going on and
then they start playing and i'm like
okay maybe they're just gonna play one
song and then they play the second song
i'm like okay maybe maybe they're gonna
play two songs and then music is gonna
come on they play five songs
after the fourth song i'm just like have
i made a terrible mistake and we've just
come i would just come just come to
bangkok thailand to see the ruse
did they end up coming over what they
did
but like
like i was just like i just remember
thinking uh i at first i was like you
know maybe it's a sporting band and then
like four songs later
i really hope i didn't just spend all
this money to see your [ __ ] knock off
museman man you're dude by the way
did they do that on purpose they have
the ruse supporting the muse maybe
unfortunately you've mastered that they
must they must have chosen them on
purpose right there's no there's no
[ __ ] way you could be a supporting
artist you change your name yeah what's
your name to the ruse
no reason why just do it yeah but don't
copy my homework too hard
i would be bricking it if i got there
they're like welcome the ruse and i
checked the chicken right now
i literally like because like i
literally went i always had to go
outside just to check that uh the main
poster said
like i was coming in to see muse perform
i go outside and it's like yes it is
muse go back in still the ruse i was
like maybe they made a mistake out front
on the
maybe they got the letters wrong i don't
know
i
i've seen enough knock-off things in
southeast asia to be like maybe they
just pretended to be muse this entire
time the thai version yeah that's right
um but yeah i saw them live and they
were absolutely
absolutely incredible i i'm shocked you
put the killers on here do you like more
than the one song
do you like more than mr bright side yes
yes i i like ruby ruby ruby that's
that's the chiefs
yeah
that's how little i know about the
killers yeah this sounds so simple
to be honest i only know mr bryce do
they have any other songs yeah they have
mr bright sides uh apparently their
latest album is really good
i actually i had sheer i think
i actually haven't heard that lately
yeah
so why are they on the list huh why are
they on the list um because i think like
the killers was my university life right
my university yeah uh i was actually
like already into the killers before
like mr brightside came to like take
over the uk scene you you were fans
before they were far field well kind of
but like they also really just exploded
onto the uk scene uh with
somebody told me um that was like that
was like the first song that really
exploded and like i was already into
indie rock at the time and for the
longest time i thought they were a
british rock band everyone does yeah
yeah yeah yeah they're like mormon
americans yeah yeah yeah yeah so like
for the longest time i thought
that they were a british rock band the
same way as like arctic monkeys were um
and you know and a lot of other british
indie bands yeah because they came out
in that time but uh yeah they i didn't
know they were from america but uh they
were like the one indie band that i
listened to still throughout university
because the reason i stopped listening
listening to a lot of indie music is
because my band broke up because we all
went to university
right um but i mean i listened to the
killers and
i don't know which album is which songs
but i know i listened to a lot of see
i'm i'm drawing a [ __ ] blank right
now yeah um i just know i've listened to
a lot of killers uh and the reason it's
on here is not only because i listened
to them a lot
uh
in university but it's also the first
band that uh me and sydney bonded over
oh oh so
so
okay so uh uh so sydney likes to quote a
lot of songs to like a lot of people
that she hung out with right and
apparently she told me that the only
time someone had completed a song lyric
that she had quoted instead of just
being like cindy what the [ __ ] are you
talking about was uh when she quoted the
killers to me via text and she was she
just randomly said
uh
somebody told me
not somebody told me uh i got soul and
i'd reply back um
the absolute irony [ __ ] me i'm deciding
this is this is i'm drawing a [ __ ]
black right now what's what's left oh my
god
i'm not a soldier is that the line is
that like this is like this is like me
trying to remember lyrics right because
i'm just like i'm just like i got salsa
i'm not a soldier or something like that
this is okay okay like i said i don't
listen to lyrics like i just i just know
because you managed to quote back that
one yeah that's that's the one line he
managed to call but yeah that's that's
the one line i managed to quote back and
uh and she was like well you're a
killer's fan you're the one you're you
are the one you you are the first person
took a very big gamble replying with
that you could have looked like a
[ __ ] idiot yeah you're like what's
wrong with god he said he's not a
soldier or something
bizarre
yeah but uh yeah so the killers hold a
very you know a very very deep place in
my heart not not only because i listen
to the killers and i am reminded of
university life um but also because it's
part of the reason that i met and bonded
with my partner that i'm with now
and i also saw them live in bangkok by
hand as well
it's so weird
we saw the drillers
this is the construction
act the fillers
we saw the drillers uh yeah i mean i
remember like the first i remember
seeing them live and the first song that
they played was mr brightside and
obviously mr bryce side is starting
strong is the song that everyone
everyone knows right um and i remember
it was such a surreal experience just
hearing a song that i'd listened to so
much in my childhood right and i it was
almost like it was it was almost like a
weird out of out of [ __ ] body
experience right where i i had had this
song that was that meant so much to me
when at one point in my life and i saw
them now at the age of like 25 26 or
something like that like way later um
and it just like a wave of just like it
was so surreal because i wa it was like
a wave of like memories and nostalgia
but also
like me living in the moment like
it's it's so weird to describe because
just hearing them live and hearing like
it was like my life had like built up to
this one moment you know
i i don't know because yeah because
because i've never seen a band that i
loved so much
as a kid um later in life until that one
moment so it was just it was just such
an incredible moment for me i will never
forget hearing mr brightside for the
first night